a recent poll released by the national
association of school nurses reveals
that two-thirds of parents with children
ages five to eleven say they are likely
to get their kids vaccinated against
covet in our pointers from a
pediatrician segment we now check back
in with dr kerry jay sinha of siena
pediatrics
thank you so much for your time today
what do you feel parents should know
about the vaccine
good afternoon um so we're excited that
the coven pfizer vaccine was approved
last week by the fda but this week by
the cdc so we are allowed to now talk
about it and recommend that children
from 5 to 11 can receive this vaccine
okay and how is the dosage adjusted for
children in that age group
so it was in the studies they actually
did uh have the children do different
doses and they found that there was a
smaller dose 10 micrograms versus a 30
micrograms for an adult uh will be the
dose that we'll be giving the children
so also you should know that to prevent
confusion the manufacturer actually
colored the vile top i believe it's
going to be green vial for our children
5 to 11 and um i think it's orange just
don't quote me on that but it's
definitely different color so it will
help minimize confusion between the
different age groups
and has your office and other other
pediatricians offices in town started
offering these yet
um so any who has signed up through
immunized nevada that
it can be a distributor of vaccines can
now
border number one and then receive them
and we have already our office has
started the process of ordering them
waiting actually for the delivery
the other thing is is that there's
several
other places like cvs and other
pharmacies the health departments
federally healthcare qualified clinics
that will be administering them too and
finally can children receive the vaccine
at the same time as other routine
vaccinations um the answer is yes
academically they can um and from a
pediatrician who runs our own practice
it's going to be a little challenging in
the beginning
we want to prove to our families that
this coveted vaccine is safe and going
to be effective and so i think a lot of
the local pediatricians may do it uh by
itself at different times throughout the
day or on the weekends um and so
everybody's going to probably have a
different system
thank you again for your time today and
once your child is vaccinated we wanted
to know what if anything changes with
school policy at ccsd a spokesperson
tells us quote if your child has been
fully vaccinated they may not have to
quarantine if they are asymptomatic
parents and guardians must provide proof
of vaccination and speak with the health
office before the child can return to
the classroom an individual is
considered fully vaccinated 14 days
after receiving the final dose of the
covet vaccine well if you are looking
for locations locally you can text your
zip code to 438
829
or you can call the number listed there
on this lower third of your screen
1-800-232-0233
we'll also have those numbers for you
with this story on our website christian